la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
bienvenue au camp des marrons situé au
guillaume dans les hauts de saint-paul
ce jardin pas comme les autres recèle
des trésors et des plantes toutes aussi
originales accompagnées par des jeunes
du centre d'insertion sportives et
culturelles du bernica l'association qui
gère ces lieux jean-paul bavol nous fait
découvrir toutes ces richesses végétales
comme ici le brain madame scène brède
faute en vitamines dont le vadis est il
le viagra pays parce qu'elle est
gramoune longtemps un média qui était
travaille beaucoup et tout ce qui est
qu'il tirait tradition lebresne madame
quand il est bon on va les voir prendre
comme ça là là hop comme ça un beau prix
cassés on mettait bon morceau de
gingembre dedans pendant ce temps le
moment avec le papa et envoyer les
enfants passaient une vacance c'est
grand mais au grand complet le soin aux
gros mareine et bonin jusqu'à
tranquillement le soir dans neuf mois la
viande du baba souvent qu'on a des 3e
jeunesse qui viennent ici ben le pied de
brême madame souvent il raconte alain
bohn cette anecdote dessus comme on
commence a connu comme aux est effectuée
tout seul mais plus qu'un simple jardin
créole le camp des marrons est aussi un
lieu magique où culture et tradition
s'entremêlent étroitement la baume veut
dire que c'est une plante culturel
qu'ils tuaient tradition par exemple les
feuilles ne peut février pour la grippe
après il ne peut prendre un bon bain
avec pouces ou là le corps nous peut
prendre par exemple imagine que tu lier
son fromage et nous va prendre deux
trois filles la bonne va mettre dans le
soulier vatché le dr fromage par exemple
qu'il arrive la saison la hausse à
dillon fleurs les gars comme ça novarica
récolter toutes les fleurs là nous met
d'un petit chat chez et nous met dans la
en moi et pas film-là mois camp laïque
donc je vais dire qu'on voit qu'on ne
parle de culture et tradition
nous l'en plein le dos et qu'on nous
parle environnement durable nos
gramounes l'été longtemps dedans par
l'obligation par harold la lutte et la
boxe c'est pour ça que nous dit il faut
à nous un grand respect pour le travail
de tout ça la balle est poursuivie dans
un quart courant
r au rythme des devinettes alors on va
commencer
cric et crac écrit guy sioui jason comme
ça mika c'est ok amy move le monde caché
qu'elles m'ont le moment n'a le droit
répondent mieux aux tâches
c'est le fils tâche la président un fort
en moi midi au moins miam n'est qu'à
vide était hélas le cas les villes de
lille et dans cochant la dame carla le
cas les villes n'a pas déjà chauffé à me
mettre le cas t elle à ronaldo
concernant messieurs dames la société
mène à la place à une combine à la place
puisque local vibre le calais ville mène
à la place peyneau ashes aux commandes
et donc les cris qui craque et c'était
comme ça legrand - la leaf est ric et
rac avec audi au conte lente
situé au guillaume saint paul la visite
du camp des marrons est aussi un
véritable voyage dans le temps à la
découverte de la culture et des
traditions créoles
c'est comme dans ton longtemps on
n'avait pas une chaise des fabriques
éléments les tables étaient faits
n'avaient que des bacs bas dessous voilà
des petits tapent fait maison
on reste dans l'esprit de la
récupération de rien ne se perd tout
tout utilisateur et et voilà tout est
utilisable pour l'environnement comme da
comme havre en fait qui donne une
magnifique salle verte
un passage à la boutique atyak restera
lui aussi un moment inoubliable
c'est toujours dans les eaux l'esprit
convivialité créole échanges parental
pour montrer qu'ils avaient des bonnes
relations avec les chinois d'aller où il
veut dire que je côtoie l'était toujours
comme ça et le petit chinois d'aller au
lit avait toujours la communication avec
de moon
donc là pays causée en même temps michel
bahou engageons à faire ils étaient
toujours habillés comme ça proposé
discuter avec les clients et maintenant
elle veut dire qu'ils passaient un
code-barres code bar kokhba ne l'a pas
le temps d'en faire don dit que le
chinois en avant l'originalité la de ce
carnet bien qu'il associe son image et
2015 espère quoi l'image toujours comme
ça et donc là nulle entraîne aménagé un
petit coin tu continues pour montrer à
la jeunesse micky bien là comment l'été
et comme on nous l'avait toujours cet
échange et partage puisque noté
wasquehaliens clarion puisque le beau
météo qui avait pas la zone euro dit et
point qu'il aurait dû marc pauly tu vas
la creuse il habite toujours le petit
l'ange incarné thème entre elles ont
tellement un petit peu en plus je
mettais ma dynamique le cscb le centre
d'insertion sportives et culturelles du
bernica a également permis à des jeunes
et des moins jeunes de trouver ici un
premier travail ou de reprendre une
activité à travers des chantiers
d'aménagement paysager notre terre
pendant ensemble parce qu'un travail
noah buffet l'apprendre faire
elle traîne de clôture aux barbes ou
abobo de palettes ou même ticket pas
trop trop haut débit est lui même né
même tes habitudes travailler clia après
la main peut que l'installation que les
bambous pour un écrit lh2 firme voilà
actuellement nous on reprenait de faire
des tonnelles faut faire monter de se
souder poids dessus
ben semaine sur un ca de fès en bambou
tradition lui traditionnel traditionnel
super impeccable il a fallu apprendre
comment planter vie chère parce que
c'est quand même premier travail presque
un professionnel donc j'ai quelqu'un qui
m'a montré comment on fait qu'expliquer
qui m'a dit ça mais je suis assez fier
quand même parce que c'est quand même un
travail que je fais que je me suis
accompli quoi c'est un partage de
savoirs peuvent également se crée lièvre
sociale et ensuite d'un demain ce jeune
là prendront la relève pour transmettre
tout ce qu'ils ont appris à les enfants
ou chinois les amis et autres
bon